and what the AI does is in real time it
understands what are the risks that are
happening while you're driving so it
looks at the road ahead of you um and
are there stop signs coming up other
vehicles pedestrians kids bicyclists it
looks at what the driver is doing and
particular what the driver paying
attention to and if they've fallen
asleep or they're distracted by food or
mobile phone and it looks at what the
vehicle's doing and increasingly we're
looking at the location history as well
so we know which locations are very
dangerous or what kind of risks happen
where all of that happens in real time
on board the vehicle and that's really
important it's different from a lot of
other AI That's used to process uh data
after the fact because our goal really
is to look five six seconds into the
future to predict is this getting
[Music]
dangerous Stefan heck welcome to a
20-minute leaders in the matis
experiment really glad to have you here
welcome pleasure to be here thanks for
having me yeah you know this is this is
a an opportunity for me again to to dive
in h and U meet another person who has
the best job in the world and uh
tackling something that you deeply care
about with the people uh you care to do
it with under a vision that motivates
you and guides you so so a lot of u a
lot of ways to look at this question
from different angles and so I'll I'll
start off Stefan tell me a little bit
about Nao and and what you're doing with
in sort of the intersection of of
artificial intelligence and Commercial
fleets and how these worlds uh are
intersecting obviously with the
explosion of AI over the last few years
um and the verticalized applications
here and just so that we can have a
little bit of background as to what what
you really do in the day-to-day yeah so
uh n as an AI company I started about 10
years ago uh we deploy AI into uh
vehicles uh working with both Fleet
owners uh vehicle manufacturers
insurance companies it's a uh
subscription service or what's called
SAS software as a service or in this
case AI as a service um so we charge per
vehicle per year uh it's a simple fee
and what the AI does is in real time it
understands what are the risks that are
happening while you're driving so it
looks at the road ahead of you um and
are there stop signs coming up other
vehicles pedestrians kids bicyclists it
looks at what the driver is doing in
particular what the driver is paying
attention to and if they' fallen asleep
or they're distracted by food or mobile
phone and it looks at what the vehicle's
doing and increasingly we're looking at
the location history as well so we know
which locations are very dangerous or
what kind of risks happen where all of
that happens in real time on board the
vehicle and that's really important
that's different from a lot of other AI
That's used to process uh data after the
fact because our goal really is to look
five six seconds into the future to
predict is this getting dangerous and
then to empower the driver to avoid that
risk before anything bad happens so it
is isn't just about you know oh you had
a collision which there's a lot of
telematic systems that's what they do
but it's about wow watch out this is
getting really scary um you should slow
down leave more following distance put
your phone away whatever it might be and
through that we are able to very very
quickly uh in a matter of days eliminate
most of the driving risks typically
between 80 and
90% And reduce the collisions that
you're going to have by about 2/3 uh in
the best case it's over 90% but
typically it's about 2/3 so it's really
phenomenal and most people don't realize
you know there's a lot of safety
Technologies out there in vehicles
airbags backup cameras uh you know if
you go back in time the break the
invention of the seat belt and if you
look at the previous best technology was
the seat belt in the 50s and 60s which
reduced collisions and injuries about
20% and you know here we are getting
about
65% reduction in in collisions it's
pretty phenomenal so it's exciting it's
it's it's why I love this this rule I
love what n does every day help me
understand a little bit better the the
landscape and the ecosystem behind where
where you're at so we're talking about
the pain point of of predictive
abilities to to be able right to prevent
different different things that could
happen you know in commercial fleets and
driving and different behaviors and then
making a recommend and then making
recommendations based on that tell me
can you can you share a little bit about
where this fits into the ecosystem of
the the Driving Experience you know in
terms of the product the car the the
where the recommendations actually take
place how does the produ actually work
yeah so today we're uh working with
commercial fleets so this would be you
know not only Long Haul Trucking which
everybody thinks about but a lot of
service fleets delivery fleets you know
the package delivery companies that come
to your house the technicians that come
and install air conditioning Cable
telephone uh Etc so it's a lot of Light
commercials Vehicles Vans and pickup
trucks as well as large trucks and and
sedans um terms of Who's involved in
this ecosystem there's the vehicle
manufacture and for if you're buying a
later model car you have the option to
put in collision avoidance system Safety
Systems unlike passenger vehicles where
they're often now standard uh for
commercial vehicles they're typically an
option package so the fleet has to
decide to to add that there's the fleet
itself which usually has a safety team
and a set of officials whose day job is
to make sure the drivers are safe and
then if you're uh a very large Fleet
you're typically self-insured but if
you're a midsize Fleet uh you have an
insurance company involved as well and
the insurance compan is really mostly
after the fact you know they they
process claims uh they may do some what
they call loss mitigation but loss
mitigation is really training after
you've had bad collisions to avoid the
next one um the safety team does a lot
of training proactively you know
particularly in the when you hire a new
driver that first 12 months is very
risky just like we all know if anybody's
ever had a teenager that first couple of
years of the teenager driving is very
risky it takes a while to to really get
good um the difference with nto is we go
into the vehicle um and if it if it
already has a compute and sensors we
just add our software but if it doesn't
we add a sensor package uh that goes on
the windshield you it's a small package
that sits on your on your wind screen
and that adds the sensors in the compute
and then in terms of your question you
know where when and where does it happen
that package in real time 15 times a
second is assessing the risk of the
situation holistically so we detect
individual risks and then we assemble
them into a in a situation assessment
for example if you're you know holding
your phone right you're you might be
doing this holding your phone up to your
ear um that's above normal risk that's
about nine times normal driving risk now
if you're looking down at your phone and
you're texting it jumps to 32 times
normal driving risk um but where it
combines is let's say you're also
speeding speeding by itself is not super
risky it's between 20 and 40% elevated
risk now again assuming you're not going
100 Mil hour then of course it's much
riskier but a little bit of speeding
like most people do it's not super
dangerous by itself and then let's take
a pedestrian Crossing uh pedestrian
Crossing is also nine times normal
driving risk but where things get really
interesting and what what Nat is
uniquely doing is we put these risks
together because if the pedestrian's
crossing and you're looking down at your
phone texting you the these two risks
don't add if they added you'd be about
32 times normal driver risk but actually
you're going to be 2,700 times normal
driver risk and anytime you take that
kind of risk where the risk is thousand
times normal driving risk you're going
to have a collision it's just a matter
of time before your look runs out so
that's where we intervene what we do is
we do a set of voice and behavioral
nudges it begins pretty gentle you know
it just a reminder put your phone down
or the speeding one for example is it
gives you this like subtle suggestion of
slowing down that's the lowest level as
you get riskier it'll give you voice
coaching so we'll say for example pull
over to use your phone and we're very
focused on what's the biggest thing you
can do to reduce your risk right now um
I have this highly technical term that
we've designed for which is when we
intervene we want the driver to go oh
because if they go oh and we
talk about oh moments that's when
the adults learn even as a as a
experienced driver you may have 30 years
of driv experience but if you have one
of these oh my God that was dangerous
moments that's where you adjust your
behavior absolutely and in the most
acute risk let's say you're about to hit
somebody or something um it's an alarm
because there's no time for you to
listen to voice think about what to do
it's just a screeching alarm to get you
to Swerve or or break and through that
we've been able to help fleets avoid
over 30,000 collisions uh in the last
two years so it's it's really you know
everybody at natto is inspired by this
mission of saving lives um it's hard to
know how many of those 30, th000
collisions would have been fatal but
based on statistics somewhere between 30
and 40 so there's you know 30 35 people
walking around today um who are only
alive because not protected
them obviously um being able to meas to
use um something that has something to
do with life saving as a metric for the
company I can only imagine it's probably
incredibly inspiring and motivating um
continue can you double click a little
bit into what sort of how do you measure
this and what how do you how do you
generate a somewhat rigorous C thinking
about translating the alerts that you
create or the work that you do towards
the impact that it has on something like
saving collisions or ultimately saving
lives obviously I'm sure part of it is
is an estimation but how do how do you
how what what signals do you bring in to
be able to then put on a big dashboard
and say hey look we as an organization
are making a huge impact because of X Y
and Z yeah it's actually pretty deeply
analytical uh you know we have a lot of
data scientists and and we get deep into
the risk science there's three parts the
first part is having really really good
AI That's rigorously trained so that
it's very quick it's very precise and it
doesn't have a lot of false positives
because if you alert somebody about a
risk that isn't there people get really
really upset it's called backseat
driving uh so if I tell you you know
slow down and there's nothing there
you're going to say what why you why you
bothering me so we don't want to be
backseat drivers so that's the AI part
and we shoot for super high Precision so
that you can detect the risk accurately
and uh it's really important to do it
fast there's a lot of dash cameras that
claim they have ai in them now a lot of
those dash cameras see only a small
number of risks and see them six seven
seconds later six or seven seconds when
you're driving is an eternity a lot
could have happened in 6 seconds right
so our technology we really focused on
detecting risks in under 100
milliseconds that's a tenth of a second
uh so that you're really instantly
seeing that risk the second part gets
into behavioral psychology you know what
what feedback do I give the driver so
that they really change because there's
a fine line between warning you about
something that you didn't see and
annoying you about something that's very
obvious right so if I'm looking at the
stop sign with my gaze telling me
there's a stop sign coming up is super
super annoying now if I'm if I'm looking
down at my phone or I'm looking over at
a person on the left and I didn't see
the stop sign and I'm not slowing down
at all then is helpful that's one of
these oh that was really dangerous
experiences um so that's the the second
most important part and then third is
how do you know what difference you made
um the way we do that is we rigorously
do a scientific controlled experiment in
every deployment so we look at the
history of that sleet we then deploy our
uh system and we observe silently for 3
weeks so that's literally just measuring
what is the risk that's going on we
found that the in general the first week
or two people are on their best behavior
because they know we're measuring it's
called the the Hawthorne effect so you
change your behavior because you know
you're being observed um but in our
experience by the third week people
forgotten all about it uh and they go
back to their normal habits and then we
rigorously measure after um and usually
we take a control group of vehicles
we're not in as well so you can
eliminate things like season changes
that are happening other things that
might have been going on right if you
have a snowstorm for example driving
behaviors change we want to be able to
compare the the fleet we were in or the
portion of the fleet we were in versus
the where we were not and so we
rigorously measure both a behavior rate
before how often were you touching your
phone turns out in a typical commercial
Fleet people use their phone seven times
per driving hour uh in other words every
9 minutes or so they're touching their
phone phones are super addictive super
dangerous uh if you take nothing away
from this conversation for your driving
other than put your phone away then
that's already a great a great result um
and um then we measure that same
behavior rate after and typically we see
you're down to um touching your phone
once every two three four hours of
driving which is great it's almost an
order of magnitude
change um and then we also measure the
Collision rate before and after so how
many collisions per million miles did
you have before an autod deployment and
how many do you have after um and that's
how we can get very quantitative the
only part of what we do that's hard to
know for sure is you know what how many
fatalities how many lives have we saved
because it's very hard to know would
this particular Collision have led to a
fatality but in in some very large
fleets that we work with you can
actually see that because you know they
might have had 10 fatalities last year
this year they have only one or two then
you know you probably saved nine lives
there and I fully get that and and I
appreciate the I appreciate the
complexity that that goes into into
measuring something like that but but it
sounds like once you're able to
articulate a a you know a reasoning and
rationale for what for how you're going
about it I can I can only imagine how
how also motivating that is for somebody
who's deeply for the on the deeply
analytical sides of the team and so I
think I think that's very cool and I'll
tell you the biggest impact isn't
actually the analytic part but is seeing
one of these moments where there was a
huge risk going on the driver wasn't
aware we alert the driver they look up
they usually have this you know surprise
shocked expression they hit the brakes
they swerve and then usually there's
some four-letter word after that where
the driver goes you know damn or or
worse than that and you know they
realize oh my God that was a dangerous
moment seeing those videos is
lifechanging you know people cheer
people celebrate like oh and and
oftentimes drivers will share that right
they become fans they say look this
saved my life uh I wouldn't be here self
incredible Stefan I I want to wish you
best of luck in your journey with NATO
it sounds sounds awesome and I can I I
can I can experience from the from just
from this conversation the how um the
impact that this has on you and and I
mean you said it yourself that the that
the things you get to do in the dayto
day can have life-changing moments and I
can only I can only aspire for for
myself and and any other entrepreneur to
be working on on things that can provide
them life life H lifechanging
experiences and that and and that they
could have an any day and so H very very
cool work and important work and I want
to wish you best of luck and thank you
again for coming on and being a part of
this experiment and uh and for sharing
your story thanks so much it's pleasure